[Musique]
José Legault Michel Surget allait à son
gay bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir On va refaire le fil si
vous le voulez bien on va écouter
monsieur boulet ça c'était il y a le 21
septembre et quelques jours un débat
Mauricie sur les immigrants et les
réactions que ça suscité puis après je
vous parlerai de Monsieur Lego on va
séparer ça va être plus clair que tout à
l'heure je vous en croyez moi mesdames
et messieurs on écoute
80% des immigrants s'en vont à Montréal
travaille pas parle pas français ou
nadhère pas aux valeurs de la société
québécoise
Jean en fait une grave erreur c'est pas
vrai
ce que dit
Monsieur boulet
dit que dit ça dans le feu de l'action
mais c'est pas une excuse qui justifie
ce que dit donc je regrette beaucoup les
propos de Monsieur boulet
ce sont des propos qui sont dangereux
parce que ils alimentent la peur de
l'autre il divise les Québécois ils sont
faux ils s'en font en plus à nouveau des
propos irresponsables de la part de la
CAQ
et j'ai eu de la difficulté à croire que
c'est à chaque fois ce sont des
accidents
quand le Premier ministre
passe une campagne électorale a cassé du
sucre sur le dos des immigrants est-ce
qu'il faut se surprendre qu'un de ces
ministres
s'engage dans ce dans la voie que ouvert
le premier ministre
c'est pas la première fois que la CAQ
envoie des drôles de signaux lui
rappelez-vous que Monsieur le goût
lui-même il y a quelques jours à peine
associer l'immigration à la violence
bon monsieur boulet s'est excusé je vous
montre le tweet je suis désolé d'avoir
mal exprimé ma pensée l'extrait
difficile ne reflète pas ce que je pense
il faut continuer à miser sur l'accueil
la francisation l'intégration des
immigrants qui sont de richesse pour le
Québec
n’empêche
José Legault autour de table là-dessus
un empêche ce qui le dit était faux là
oui la partie Montréal c'est vrai qu'ils
viennent à Montréal les deux autres
éléments c'est à fond il travaille puis
adhérer aux valeurs mais là en tout cas
à vous oui c'est ça il y avait trois
éléments il faut il y avait aussi
l'effet qui partent en français
le problème c'est non seulement que
c'était faux mais c'était c'est que
c'est tellement grossier que ça ne fait
qu'animenter les pires préjugés possible
sur les immigrants ça c'est le premier
constat mais c'est suivi d'une
interrogation parce que j'en voulais
quand même a été un bon ministre
lui connaît pas de fibres xénophobes non
plus moi je trouve que c'est un mystère
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qui
lui a passé par la tête pour qu'ils
disent de telles fausseté et qui
alimente des préjugés on ne le sera
probablement jamais mais pour moi ça
reste un mystère oui parce qu'il a une
bonne réputation on disait plutôt
aujourd'hui est une grosse gaffe qui
tombe sur un ministre qui avait la
réputation d'être un gentleman un homme
mais peu importe Michel Saugier ce qui
le dit comme dit José ça alimente les
préjugés les gens on sait bien ils
travaillent pas viennent à Montréal puis
on a leur quartier puis il s'intègre pas
Premier ministre l'immigration
d'ailleurs monsieur le groupe précision
a dit ça le disqualifie pour être
l'immigration
au moins bien réagi en design ne sera
plus ministre de l'Immigration c'est une
bonne décision parce qu'effectivement
même si c'est pas le plus avec vous je
pense avec vous
et c'est un hasard je l'avais en
entrevue puisque je fais tous les chefs
les uns à l'arrière des autres et
c'était François Legault ce matin donc
on l'a questionné là-dessus on lui a
fait jouer l'extrait il a écouté son
ministre il y a du bien évidemment il ne
sera plus ministre de l'Immigration ça
ira un autre un autre joueur ce n'est
pas d'accord avec José Michel c'est pas
le joueur le plus incendiaire de
l'équipe de François Legault
certainement pas alors je me serais pas
attendu ce que ce soit lui qui a une
déclaration comme celle-là je n'ai
aucune idée de ce qui s'est passé dans
sa tête peut-être que au fil du temps et
ça je fais attention mais peut-être
qu'on fait du temps on a donné un peu
trop d'espace à la CAQ à des discours
qui était méfiants envers les immigrants
et que il y a certains des députés
candidats ministres qui se donnent un
peu plus de latitude que ce que qu'il
devrait peut-être que ça fait partie
aussi de l'équation quand le chef
maîtrise pas tout à fait les dossiers de
l'immigration fait parfois des amalgames
un peu douteux entre la violence
l'extrémiste ni valeurs je dis pas que
il a la permission de n'importe quoi
mais peut-être que là on a laissé un peu
trop de marge de manœuvre à la CAQ sur
ces questions-là ne pas senti le chef
toujours être très en contrôle du
dossier ça peut avoir joué un peu aussi
mais c'est clair que on se serait passé
de cette question là aujourd'hui les
avantages de François Legault on
s'arrachait les cheveux sur la tête en
se disant pas encore l'immigration on va
passer une autre journée en train
d'essayer de contrôler ce message-là
c'est comme si on n'était pas assez d'un
extrême à l'autre au Québec là avant on
n'osait pas du tout débattre de ces
questions là c'est tabou vous n'avez
peur de faire traiter de raciste et tout
ça et de l'autre là c'est on dirait on
dirait que c'est la saison est ouverte
pour dire n'importe quoi là oui José
vous alliez dire ouais c'est ça mais ça
nous amène au problème de fond avec le
gouvernement sortant c'est que oui on
peut débattre de ces questions là
partout en accident au départ de ces
questions là tout est dans la manière
et
au gouvernement on essaie ça non plus on
sait pas pourquoi les gens ont permis
mot plutôt que de discuter de la
question de l'immigration sous l'aspect
évidemment de la richesse que ça
constitue mais comment la carte propose
de mieux intégrer de mieux francisé
d'Alice vers des propositions concrètes
qui invitent les immigrants assez
intégrer et non pas qu'il est blanc
parce que le français recule ou ceci ou
cela ou etc bon parce que lorsqu'on
parle de régionalisation de
l'immigration pour moi ce que j'entends
c'est un abus d'échec dans la région de
Montréal mais la vue d'échec il est
celui des gouvernants il est pas celui
des immigrants donc moi c'est sûr que
j'aimerais entendre je pense que c'est
ce que ce que beaucoup de Québécois
aimeraient entendre très bien je pense
qu'un autre panier
ce qui est difficile aussi là-dedans
c'est que le premier ministre n'arrête
pas la discussion et dit si vous
n'acceptez pas ma solution 50 000 ans
c'est suicide en la nation québécoise on
peut pas on peut pas discuter là on peut
pas discuter de ça et les gens de la
Chambre de commerce je pense pas de
suicide de la nation québécoise en
disant on en veut plus quelque chose qui
se débat mais depuis le début le
gouvernement et le Premier ministre au
premier chef essaie d'arrêter le débat
une fois que j'ai dit quelque chose
parlait plus justement on va écouter
monsieur Lego parce que c'est tout à
fait légitime il peut incarner cette
politique de cette prise de position en
disant au-delà de 50000 nous on juge que
pour la langue française on n'arrive pas
à les intégrer voici pourquoi voici pour
soi mais de dire puis là on va l'écouter
que c'est
quasi suicidaire pour le Québec d'un
accueillir plus on écoute
on n'aura pas stoppé le déclin du
français je pense que pour la nation
québécoise qui veut protéger le français
ça serait un peu suicidaire d'aller
augmenter
bon voilà tour de table as-tu Alec il
peut penser qu'il ne puis de toute façon
il le dit depuis le début
50000 on doit pas augmenter ce seuil là
pour telle telle raison mais en plus
suicidaire est-ce que encore là c'est
pas d'en ajouter une couche qui qui rend
ce qu'on dit suicide on dit mort qui ont
dit mort c'est la louisianisation qui
revient là
c'est une image forte que François
Legault a utilisé je lui ai posé la
question à mon émission aussi il dit ben
je parlais des seuils de 70 à 80 000 de
Québec solidaire ou du Parti libéral
aussi beaucoup trop en plus une
garantissent pas qu'on va au moins avoir
80% des nouveaux arrivants qui parlent
français donc ce n'est pas capable
d'avoir une proportion très élevée de
nouveaux arrivants en français dit oui
une question là tu revis de la nation
survie de la langue donc il prend un peu
le thème qu'il a utilisé au printemps
oui c'est des mots qui sont quand même
assez forts et qui arrivent évidemment
dans la même journée où il y a l'ex des
gens boulets qui refait surface donc
évidemment ça fait ça grossit la
controverse autour de l'accueil des
immigrants qu'avez-vous pensé de ça donc
on est à ranger à monsieur Legault
Michel et José Michel d'abord
comme je disais c'est empêcher le débat
et se dire il ne peut pas y avoir un
autre chiffre que le mien vous à la
Chambre de Commerce vous voulez la mort
de la nation québécoise c'est pas vrai
je suis le blanc pense pas ça là la
Chambre de commerce c'est un débat qui
doit se faire dans le et d'autre part
les chiffres qu'on a cité aujourd'hui à
l'encontre de Monsieur boulet c'est
quand même que 80% des immigrants
parlent français sont capables d'avoir
une conversation en français c'est la
question du recensement qui leur est
posé c'est quand même pas trop mal faut
pas commencer à dire ces gens-là sont
tous à Montréal il y en a aucun qui
parle français alors un moment donné si
les faits sont pas bon on peut pas
arriver de bonne conclusion oui José
moi j'irai jusqu'à dire que c'est un
faux débat dans les faits parce que bon
ça ces chiffres là que ce soit 50 000 à
la CAQ 70000 chez les libéraux 35000 au
PQ etc on entend pas de réel
justification
puis de toute manière le Québec
accueille dans les faits beaucoup plus
que 50 ml cette année si on considère
les immigrants temporaires etc toute la
partie le Québec de contrôle pas donc
moi je reviens à ce point là t'es
arrêtez de nous parler de chief arrêtez
de faire peur au monde et qu'est-ce que
vous proposez pour que ça se passe mieux
comment vous vous quel politique vous
allez adopter pour que ça se passe de
meilleure manière c'est tout c'est ça
une campagne électorale mais semble-t-il
en tout cas semble-t-il c'est pas de
faire des procès soit l'immigration soit
aux autres parties parce qu'ils ont pas
les bons chiffres ils ont pas les bons
seuils
en tout cas selon le Premier ministre et
l'autre question donc ça pose ce débat
l'autre question que ça pose ce débat
si on a accroît les sondages puis il
faut rester prudent on est à 5 jours
mais quand même son accroît en
augmentation
Joseph c'est vraiment une journée comme
ça la carte est en augmentation partout
au Québec sauf dans la région de
Montréal est-ce qu'il y a pas ce danger
là de créer encore plus bien sûr qu'il y
a des différences sociologiques puis
culturelles puis tout ça à Montréal et
d'ailleurs mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un
danger
d'avoir encore plus de Québec Michel C
oui
on se retrouve avec
deux Québec et surtout un gouvernement
qui est hostile à Montréal
c'était pas toujours le cas puis je veux
dire il y a plein de dossiers qui se
règle avec la Ville de Montréal avec les
mais une fois de temps en temps et sur
tes dossiers qui touchent des valeurs
sensibles
on dirait que le gouvernement
utilise ça comme
pour diviser le Québec entre la grande
région de Montréal et le reste du Québec
c'est peut-être populaire dans certains
endroits mais ça fait pas des lendemains
très utiles pour le gouvernement là
c'est électoral ça va peut-être donner
des sièges ça va peut-être pas aider à
la gouvernance le lendemain d'élection
qu'est-ce que vous voyez là un danger de
d'accroître encore plus l'écart entre
Montréal et le reste du Québec
que circonscription où on devrait être
compétitif je pense à Maurice Richard
par exemple qui a une tique dans le nord
de l'île de Montréal ou dans Verdun où
on est compétit peut-être
qu'effectivement il y aura quelques
moments de la campagne électorale ou
François Legault pourra se dire je l'ai
pas peut-être échapper moi-même c'est ça
le conscription là ouais José je sais
pas si vous aviez entendu la question
mais je posais la question qu'est-ce que
ça dit sur les deux Québec là est-ce que
est-ce qu'on ne fait pas presque exprès
avec des déclarations comme ça de
d'antagoniser Montréal et le reste du
Québec
on y voit deux choses la première c'est
que bon c'était cette inquiétude de la
CAQ face à la montée du Parti
conservateur et d'une base qui est très
réceptive à ce genre de discours là
disons-le entier Montréal qui est une
espèce de
complexe des persécution lequel est
Montréal et leurs regards Québec de haut
les aime pas les gens de Québec etc ce
qui est complètement faux évidemment
est-ce que ça fait là encore comme pour
l'immigration c'est que ça nourrit des
préjugés
inutilement et là c'est des préjugés
contre les Montréalais
je sais pas c'est on voit pas vraiment
l'objectif c'est un objectif purement
clientéliste il me semble qu'il y aurait
peut-être d'autres manières de
concurrencer monsieur DM que celui-là
voilà merci beaucoup à vous trois on a
réussi à se parler à s'entendre merci
José Michel allait à très bientôt au
revoir au revoir